Speaker 1: Today, I'm going to be speaking with
attorney Peter Muji, who is a senior partner at
Levon Papantonio Rafferty and also chair of their
Securities and Business Litigation Department.
We're going to be talking about this proposed
twenty six billion dollar settlement against some
of the pharmaceutical industry's biggest players.
Some of the details which we talked about earlier
this week. Peter, it's great to have you on.
Speaker 4: First of all,
thanks for having me, David. Appreciate it.
Speaker 1: So talk to us about first this. This is
an opioid related settlement. Just to remind our
audience, as we talked about earlier this week,
talk talk to us about the genesis of this. How did
these four organizations first become the subject
of this case? How long has this been going on?
Speaker 4: I'm going to put those in two different
buckets and we'll talk about the manufacturers
quickly. Yeah, the manufacturer, which is the
JMJ story Change, is both a manufacturer in an
importer of raw opium. And they marketed and
promoted the opium here in the US, similar to a
Purdue story. And those cases started earlier.
The beginning of the manufacture cases
was 2014 ish. The distributor cases,
which are the Big Three and account for
twenty one billion of the twenty six billion,
really didn't start getting filed by the local
governments until late. Twenty, sixteen, beginning
twenty seventeen. And their responsibilities,
while overlapping with the manufacturers,
are a little different. They have an obligation
to review every order, whether it's suspicious
because it's large sized frequency pattern and
they're supposed to halt shipment and do due
diligence. They didn't do it. That's simply their
responsibility under the federal regs and why
they're on the hook for the twenty one billion.
Speaker 1: So in general, when people talk about
opioids, you can look at essentially any part of
the chain of how these ultimately get to consumers
and find concerning behavior. So you could look at
doctors and overprescribing for a period of time,
although in some places that has been mitigated,
at least to some degree. You can talk about the
manufacturers in terms of the clinical trials,
sometimes being accused of misrepresenting how
long the medications are good for in order to
justify FDA approval as being better than what's
already out there. You can talk about distributors
using sales reps to encourage the purchase and
prescription of more like at every point there's
there are things that you can find that go wrong.
Speaker 4: You can even blame the DEA.
Yeah, I mean, there's enough finger
pointing to go around. You're absolutely right.
Speaker 1: So my question, Peter, is in this case,
with regard to the four companies in question,
what are what is the alleged wrongdoing
that you were going after in the case
Speaker 4: with the distributors and the
manufacturers? But primarily the distributors are
charged under federal law with designing a system
to identify orders of unusual size, frequency
or pattern. We'll call those suspicious orders.
And once they flag a suspicious order,
they are required to hold the order
and perform due diligence before they shipped
it. And we have been able to track their
system that they were supposed to design
going back decades. And suffice it to say,
to until 2013, 14, 15, there really was virtually
no system in place. So the runaway growth
of the opiate epidemic was driven in large part
that opiate pills were just flying out the front
door with no oversight. And that's what they were
supposed to do. And the reason why they're on the
hook now in 14, 15, 16, it got better, but
it still really wasn't fixed. And until this
injunctive relief in the settlement agreement
that requires them to create a clearinghouse
spotting red flags run by a third party,
I think we'll finally get to some real
meaningful red flag test on the on the distributor
side. The manufacturers are a little different in
that they have the same responsibilities
but a little further up the food chain
and that it's very difficult for a manufacturer to
stop a shipment from the distributor. But they're
also supposed to be performing due diligence
and reviewing inside of this closed system for
suspicious orders. But what we found was, is that
the manufacturers went out and educated doctors
on the lack of addictiveness of the pills and
they were safe. And the the information coming
from the manufacturers was often misleading,
so overlapping, but a little bit different
on the manufacturer themes or side of the case.
Speaker 1: Is it fair to say right now that
the nature of the opioid crisis in
the United States is not quite as
severe as it was when some of. These cases
started or is that the wrong perspective,
Speaker 4: wrong perspective, it's actually
worse. So what's happened now is we have this
whole generation of primarily 20 to 40 year olds
that are are addicted to pills. And if we cut
the spigot off of pills, the addictive nature of
opium, and we've known this for hundreds of years,
going back to we've had multiple wars over opium.
We've had opium problems here in the United States
going back to the 70s with heroin. So what we've
seen now is we've started to ratchet down the
number of pills is that heroin and fentanyl has
just spiked there. Totally inversely correlated
pills go down, heroin and fentanyl go up.
And as a result, last year, deaths were 30
percent higher than they were the year before
related to opiate overdoses. So we are not
anywhere near out of the out of the problem zone.
Speaker 1: These cases take years. In many cases,
they can be very expensive, even from
the standpoint of the law firms that that
are carrying these cases out. Can you talk a
little bit about exactly what your role was
within this? Because these are major undertakings
with a ton of lawyers doing different things.
Speaker 4: We had it was I'm really proud
to be part of this whole operation, but
our firm formed a consortium of law firms, meaning
a group of law firms, a West Virginia law firm,
a Dallas firm. And we were the architects of
the distributor case. We were the first ones
in the country that filed the distributor cases,
almost 70 percent of the cases. In the first year
we filed, we were the architects behind the
distributor case. And just as importantly,
we were the group of firms that recovered the
Archos database in the Archos database tracks.
Every single pill manufactured in the US shipped
to a distributor and then shipped to a pharmacy.
We were able to track every one of those pills
and then we designed a red flag system that we
put on top of every one of those pills in the
US. So when you saw one hundred billion pills
distributed in the US from six to 14, that was
us. So we were able to create a red flag system
on top of Archos and that that identified
the orders that should have been popped
along the way with due diligence on them. We were
able to implement that or include that into our
our litigation showing what the defendants could
have done along the way to prevent this epidemic.
So we've been a huge part of that distributor
case, our firm and our group of firms,
Paul Farrell out of West Virginia and Baron
Imbil, along with our shop in Pepitone Raverty.
Speaker 1: In a case like this, what's the
general approach of the defense counsel
for the corporations? And my question is
really tailored at this. Is it a defense
that is substantive that the average person could
understand, or is it a defense that's basically
miring you in technicalities and obscurity?
Speaker 4: It's both. The technicalities and
the obscurities are typically at the end
the motion practice level. And depending
on whether the case is tried in front of a jury
or a judge, it's primarily finger pointing where
you started the show off with pointing at
doctors and pointing at patients and blaming
everyone besides looking in the mirror. And that's
what's really cool about this, is the settlement
agreement that we're taking into our clients.
At least the distributors have tried to address
the mess that they participated in creating and
are looking in the mirror saying, what? What can
we do? It's a long term problem. We need to have
a long term solution. We've got other defendants
that are distributors like Walgreens and CVS and
Wal-Mart that had even better visibility than the
distributors because they were distributors and
pharmacies. So if they were getting shipments from
three pharmacies, I'm sorry, three different
distributors, that Walgreens could see every one
of them. And and so there's still finger pointing
and not trying to come to the table and see what
they can do to be part of the solution. So
it's it's a it's going to take everybody
looking in the mirror, figuring out what they
could have done better and contributing to the
solution rather than this continued. The reason
why we're here is because of the DEA or because
of the doctors. Right. Or because of the victims.
I mean, blaming the DEA is ridiculous. It's like
blaming the police officer for getting a speeding
ticket. I mean it. But they're throwing everything
but the kitchen sink on the defense side.
Speaker 1: When we covered the proposed settlement
a few days ago, which is this total of twenty six
billion, twenty one plus five for the different
parties involved, I got a bunch of emails, you
know, ten or twelve emails from viewers saying,
hey, you know, to the extent that this is
going to compensate some victims, that's great.
But in terms of holding these companies
accountable in a way. They say, wow,
that almost took us down, we can't do that again,
that it's not effective, they say, because these
companies price in the fact that at some point
this is potentially going to happen. It's just
sort of like a probability curve. And they say,
you know, over the next 20 years, we should
consider that there's going to be some number of
billions of dollars that we may have to pay out.
We've already got that calculated in and it's
not ultimately going to affect us or force us
to change our behavior. What do you say to that?
Speaker 4: That's those are great questions. And
the your your viewers are entirely correct. Quite
frankly, it's the way our whole system works. And
there isn't personal accountability at the
corporate level that if they get caught,
essentially the the stockholders, the shareholders
pay these fines. Right. No one pays them. So it
is short. The whole system is designed to drive
short term profits up. So senior level management
options package and stock Patchett packages their
compensation levels, store saw and then push the
problem in the liability down the further down
the timeline for the shareholders to pay until
we start holding people accountable. So they pay
these fines and they're personally accountable.
Heaven forbid we actually send somebody to jail.
We won't see conduct changes. Now, this is one
of the things that's cool about this settlement is
that the settlement includes game changing conduct
requirements that are transformative. We will
see meaningful change within the supply chain
industry. So this won't happen again. It's not
going to be overnight, but we will see fixes
in this money is also not going to coughers to
fix potholes or go to budget deficits. Almost
90 percent of the settlement proceeds are being
used to treat the opiate epidemic, which is also
very, very important. So the money is going to
fix the problem and then there's conduct changes
that will prevent this from happening again.
Speaker 1: Last question. What's the timing of
I mean, it's being referred to as a proposed
settlement right now. When might we actually
see the money start to change hands?
Speaker 4: Well, one of the things that
we negotiated was an accelerated payment.
So the first payments going into escrow
this year in August, September of this year, it
will stay in escrow until we reach critical mass.
And critical mass is just sign on from an approval
from the cities and counties across the country,
across the country on the timeline. I see that
happening right at the beginning of next year.
So first quarter of next year, the cities
and counties will receive two payments,
one for twenty twenty one and one for twenty
twenty two. They'll get the second payment in July
and by July of twenty twenty three they'll have
the third payment. So within 18 months from
January twenty twenty two to July of twenty
twenty three, the first three payments will
come in the door, which we can really will be a
catalyst to really make some meaningful change.
Speaker 1: Yeah. For the speed at which we're
used to these things moving that seems quite,
quite, quite reasonable. I guess this is what I
would say. We've been speaking with Peter Mawji,
an attorney, senior partner at Levon
Papantonio Rafferty. Peter, great to speak to
speaking with you today and glad
to see that this is moving forward.
Speaker 4: Thanks, David.
Appreciate you having me.